[Applause]
one thing fans were dying to know is
about new music I know I know I'm big on
the marination process I have to make
sure that the details are all there
after a long wait
Christina Aguilera is a finally back
with new music the superstar dropped her
first song in six years accelerate this
week it's the lead single off her new
album liberation out June 15
[Music]
now the album does not feature the long
room our duet with ex Tina's a one-time
friend of me pink we hugged it out it's
that simple and I feel so good about
that and we also we did a song together
but it does include a surprise collab
with longtime Christina Stan
Demi Lovato it means so much to me to
have the recognition that I've gotten
from artists that I grew up listening to
and practicing too and like trying to
hit the high notes that Christina hits
and and Kelly Clark said I mean just
like to get recognition from them is a
dream come true
Demi and Xtina both opened up to
Billboard about the new record with
Christina partly blaming her time on the
voice with delaying her new music my
soul needs to breathe outside of the
show mama needs to be there for her own
dreams and passions too and Christina
says she'll never return to the NBC
singing competition quote you realize
it's not about music it's about making
good TV moments and massaging a story I
didn't get into this business to be a
television show host and to be given all
these rules
[Music]
[Music]